البعد الانساني هناك زاويه ايضا نريد ان
نضيء عليها فيما يتعلق بالوضع الاقتصادي
لهؤلاء النازحين وهؤلاء المواطنين
الفلسطينيين الذين في معظمهم باتوا بلا
عمل نتيجه الظروف التي لا تسمح بعوده احد
الى اي نوع من انواع الاعمال التي يمكن
القيام بها كيف يتدبرون امورهم من هذه
الناحيه ربما تتساوى الاوضاع بالنسبه لمن
يعمل وبالنسبه لمن لا يعمل فجميع ما يدخل
الى قطاع غزه هي مساعدات من يعمل ومعه
اموال لا يستطيع الشراء لان جميع هذه
المساعدات هي متواجده لدى مؤسسات ولدى
وكاله الغوث وهي من توزع هذه المساعدات
وبالتالي المساعدات هي التي تحتاج ان تصل
بشكل اكبر الى الناس الى السكان لكن
الاخطر من كل ذلك كما تحدثت هم هؤلاء
الذين ما زالوا بلا عمل كانت اعمالهم
يوميه نحن نتحدث عن قطاع غزه الذي كان
يعاني 50% من سكانه من البطاله وبالتالي
الان هؤلاء جميع سكان قطاع غزه اغلبهم بات
هم من انضموا الى صفوف البطاله من جراء
هذه الحرب الاسرائيليه المستمره على
القطاع اغلب الاعمال توقفت اغلب العمال
سرحوا من اعمالهم اغلب المصانع توقفت
وبالتالي اعداد البطاله في ظل هذه الاوضاع
بكل تاكيد هي اوضاع هي اعداد كبيره هذه
الاموال التي كانت تصل اليهم وان كانت
قليله كانت تسد رمقهم وتسد رمق عائلاتهم
الان هم باتوا بلا ماوى بلا غذاء وبلا
علاج ولا يستطيعون توفير ادنى مقومات
الحياه واذا كنا نتحدث عن الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه فنحن نتحدث بالاخص عن مدينه
رفح التي باتت الاكثر اكتظاظا والاكثر
ازدحاما وفي ظل هذه الاعداد الكبيره البنى
التحتيه لا لا تتحمل كل هذه الظروف المياه
مقطوعه عن هذه المدينه بشكل كبير كل 10
ايام تصل المياه لمده يوم واحد وبالتالي
هذه المدينه باتت كل الارصفه كل الشوارع
كل المناطق فيها خيام منصوبه في ظل اوضاع
برد في ظل اوضاع واحوال جويه سيئه في ظل
برد قارص في ظل رياح تزيل هذه الخيام
وتقتلع وبالتالي الظروف المعيشيه لكل
هؤلاء السكان الذين يعيشون في رفح كان
يعيش في رفح 300000 نسمه اليوم مليون و300
ال نسمه ظروف ماساويه وكارثه الامراض
تنتشر لا يوجد لديهم اموال لشراء اي شيء
ان كان متوفر اصلا في الاسواق واغلب
الاشياء غير متوفره ومقومات الحياه
والمواد الاساسيه هي غير متوفره وان كانت
متوفره بشكل بسيط جدا من خلال المساعدات
لكنها لا تكفي لكل هذه الاعداد بالاضافه
الى ان سكان مدينه غزه وشمال القطاع
المساعدات لا تصلهم بسبب منع جيش الاحتلال
من وصول هذه المساعدات اليهم بالتالي كل
الظروف الان هي ظروف ماساويه وكارثه على
كافه انحاء القطاع وزاويه اخرى ايضا هشام
ترتبط بهؤلاء الاطفال الذين باتوا لا
يستطيعون الذهاب الى مدارسهم وتوقفت
المدارس بطبيعه الحال في كل كل قطاع غزه
الى اي مدى ايضا هذا هو جزء من مظلمه
كبيره يتعرض لها اطفال قطاع غزه قبل ان
تجيبني هشام منوه فقط بهذا الخبر العاجل
مراسل الجزيره يقول ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يبدا منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى توغلا جديدا
على اكثر من محور في غزه وشمالها وههو
ايضا ما كنا قد تحدثنا عنه قبل قليل اذا
هناك تجدد لمحاور قتال
في عده مناطق من غزه وشمال قطاع غزه اضف
الى ذلك ما شهدناه من تصاعد في العمليات
الجويه وكذلك القصف المدفعي من قبل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على الشمال والوسط
اود اليك هشام ان كنت قد سمعت
السؤال الاتصالات للاسف لليوم الخامس
مقطوعه ولم اسمع السؤال بالكاد نستطيع
توفير بعض الانترنت للاتصال والتواصل معكم
مياده اذا بالامكان ات السؤال سال ايضا عن
الاثار الكارثيه والمظلوم المرتبطه بما
يتعرض له الاطفال من عدم قدرتهم على
الحصول على حقهم في التعليم
كذلك بالفعل لمده ثلاثه اشهر والمدارس
مغلقه وحتى عوده ومع ايقاف اذا توقفت
الحرب فعو هؤلاء الاطفال لهذه المدارس هي
ايضا مهمه مستحيله بسبب ان العديد من
المدارس دمرت العديد من المدارس هي تحولت
الى مراكز الاواء وبالتالي الاطفال هنا
اوضاعهم صعبه للغايه اذا كنا نتحدث عن
التعليم فهذا ربما الان بالنسبه اليهم كرف
لان الاوضاع المعيشيه التي يعيشونها في ظل
هذه الظروف هي صعبه للغايه وكارثه نحن
امام مستشفى وهو مستشفى ربما هو الوحيد
الذي يقدم الخدمات للنازحين بالاضافه الى
مستشفى ابو يوسف النجار لكن الضغط على ابو
يوسف النجار على المستشفى هو بشكل اكبر من
قبل الجرحى من قبل الشهداء لانه المستشفى
الاساسي في رفح و بالتالي بعض المستشفيات
الخاصه كهذا المستشفى مستشفى الكويت في
رفح هو الذي يقدم للنازحين الخدمات الطبيه
للمرضى وبالتالي كان يستقبل هذا المستشفى
قبل الحرب نحو 40 مريض اليوم يستقبل 1400
مريض ولك ان تتخيلي اعداد الاطفال منهم
تصل الى 400 الى 700 طفل في اليوم هؤلاء
الاطفال هم يعانون من جراء امراض مختلفه
الامراض المعديه تنتقل اليهم ايضا في ظل
الجو والبرد ايه هناك اوضاع سيئه ل لدى
هؤلاء الاطفال ناهيك عن التغذيه التغذيه
السيئه التي يعانون منها والتي العائلات
لا تستطيع توفير الغذاء الجيد لهذه لهؤلاء
الاطفال ولا تستطيع توفير الادويه الجيده
لهؤلاء الاطفال بالكاد نستطيع توفير بعض
الادويه للكبار فما بالك للاطفال وهذه
الادويه هي ادويه بديله هي ادويه ربما غير
متخصصه في كثير من الاحيان وكثير من هذه
الادويه غير متوفره في المستشفيات بالتالي
الاطفال يعانون ربما هم الاكثر من ضغوط
نفسيه من ح من عدم قدرتهم على الحصول على
حقهم في التعليم ولا الحق في الدواء ولا
الحق في العلاج ولا اي من حقوق هؤلاء
الاطفال متوفره الان في غزه ايضا الاخطر
من كل ذلك انهم ايضا يستهدفوا ويقتلوا
وربما جل الاطفال جل الاصابات وال ايضا من
الشهداء هم من الاطفال والنساء لان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يتعمد قصف المنازل المدنيه
الفلسطينيه منذ بدايه هذه الحرب ونحن نرصد
القصف يشتد من بعد منتصف الليل اي عندما
يعود الاطفال والنساء الى هذه المنازل
والى هذه الخيام التي بات يقصفها الجيش
الاسرائيلي لا سما في رفح بات يقصف الخيام
والخيام ممتلئه عن بكره ابيها بالاطفال
والنساء وبالتالي الاطفال هم الاكثر عرضه
والاكثر تعرضا في ظل هذه الحرب لكوارث
مختلفه صحيه وبيئيه وانسانيه شكرا جزيلا
لك من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت